Luffy was inspired by Shanks to become a
great pirate but what if that wasn't the
only thing that he learned from Shanks
because as we all know Shanks is a
legendary swordsman or even better what
if Luffy had a completely different
Mentor than Shanks to begin with which
leaves us with one of the maybe Most
Fascinating questions in all of One
Piece what would have happened if
instead of eating a devil fruit Luffy
had been trained to become a powerful
swordsman instead and let kicked this
off where any good pirate Story begins
back in a bar and it is here of course
that hungry child Luffy is about to eat
this devil fruit but to really set up
out what if scenario this time around
Shanks actually snatches the devil fruit
away from Luffy in time and Luffy is of
course Furious and demands to have the
fruit back but Chens and lucky Ru here
finally explain what a devil fruit is
and why Luffy can't have it however this
isn't good enough for Luffy because come
on what kid wouldn't want to eat a
strange purple fruit that gives you
crazy po so he tries to steal the devil
fruit anyways multiple times and so to
finally stop Luffy Shanks makes a deal
with him if Luffy doesn't try to eat the
fruit Shanks instead will teach him how
to use a sword and uh oh boy here we go
this is about to get absolutely insane
because of course Luffy immediately
agrees and they get right into training
and honestly Luffy is really going to
need it because at this point he's
probably more like to cut off his own
foot than to hit an actual opponent but
of course as we know Shanks wouldn't
actually give him a real sword yet so
he'll have a wooden Practice Sword for
now and maybe a small dagger or
something and that means that for the
next couple of months and years Luffy
will be training with a sword and each
time that Shanks Comes Back to the
Island Luffy is going to be super
excited to show off his new moves and
just to make this absolutely clear Luffy
here still wants to very much become
pirate king that part hasn't changed at
all and shank still gives him the straw
hat but since he's now training to be a
swordsman he will also want to someday
surpass Shanks now of course Shanks
would think that that is absolutely
hilarious and will probably tell Luffy
that he would have to become the
strongest swordsman in the world or
something like that which yeah now means
that in addition to Luffy's secret dream
and his desire to become pirate king we
have to add the world's strongest
swordsman to his list of dreams as well
however sord training on his own can't
last forever and eventually Luffy will
probably beg Shanks to take him along
with him now of course Shanks will most
likely still think that he's not ready
but he would probably agree that Luffy
needs someone else to practice with so
in our next massive change to Luffy's
Story the red pirates take Luffy to find
a new master and now you might be
thinking that Luffy is about to go off
on some Grand Adventure but he's not
quite ready for that yet and so instead
Shanks just drops Luffy off at this new
nearby dojo and let me tell you things
are about to get super interesting
because this is of course the ishin dojo
where Zoro trained during his childhood
as well so yeah that's right Luffy and
Zoro will meet way earlier in the story
and I can just imagine young Luffy and
Zoro instantly becoming fear's Rivals
and if we're being honest probably good
friends along the way as well since both
of them will be getting beat up by the
daughter of the dojo Master kinaa
however each of their desires to become
the world's strongest swordsman or
swords woman I guess is going to lead to
a ton of really intense training and a
lot of really Fierce duels now there's
really no telling how long this period
in Luffy's life would possibly last but
let's just say that after a year or so
something happens that is going to
completely change Luffy's life forever
because as we know when Shanks first
returned to the Grand line he told
people about this one kid in the East
blue who reminds him a lot of the former
pirate king and even more so now because
Luffy is actually also using a sword
just like Roger did and this bit of news
has now caught the interest of one man
in particular and so one day at the dojo
during another round of Zoro and Luffy
beating up each other a small Ship Sails
up to the village and out of that ship
walks a man with a large black blade on
his back who is of course none other
than the current strongest swordsman in
the world dracule mihawk get ready for
this okay so of course the boys will
want to immediately charge in and
challenge mihawk but Kina would very
wisely hold them down while the warlord
talks to the dojo Master Koso but as you
well know you simply can't hold Luffy
back so let's say that he escapes and
charges mihawk with a katana from the
dojo now this could very well be the end
of swordsman Luffy but let's be for
giving here and I imagine that mihawk
whips out his Tiny Little Neck dagger
and allows Luffy to test himself self a
little bit but yeah come on I mean
there's absolutely no way that Luffy is
going to do anything against this man
and eventually mihawk just sends him
flying across the village however this
is Luffy that we're talking about so of
course he would just get up and come
charging right back at mihawk and while
The Swordsman does praise His
determination he then smacks Luffy again
knocks him out and then decides that he
has seen enough before he heads back to
the ship though I could imagine him
sharing drinks with Kido who has always
seemed like a quite respectable
swordsman himself and while the kits
including Zoro Luffy and Kina are
obviously excluded here that doesn't
stop them from sneaking a Peak at
mihawk's legendary sword yodu eventually
though time is up and mihawk does decide
to leave Zoro is still itching to
challenge mihawk himself but kinaa keeps
a firm hold on him to keep him from
making the very same mistake as Luffy so
I guess that could have been really bad
but the kids immediately jump back into
training after being very much energized
by the surprise visitor there's only one
problem though Luffy is nowhere to be
seen so um where is he you ask did he
get knocked into the forest and get lost
is he crying at his failure to beat
mihawk no of course not come on this is
Luffy we're talking about and it turns
out that after mihawk has sailed quite
far from the island and from the East
blue he turns around and finds Luffy
being dragged Along by a hope that he
had tied to mihawk's ship you know kind
of similar to uh this guy right here now
when Luffy finally manages to climb up
onto the ship he expects mihawk to be
very annoyed but of course with mihawk's
observation hockey he already knew that
Luffy was there all along and so when
mihawk finally asks what Luffy actually
wants the young swordsman demands that
mihawk would train him so that he can
one day surpass him and honestly at this
point it's very possible that mihawk
would just throw Luffy off of the ship
but let's let's imagine that with
Luffy's determination plus what mihawk
already knows about him from Shanks he
tells Luffy that if he can hang onto the
outside of the ship all the way through
reverse Mountain then he will actually
train the boy now Luffy will of course
obviously be very excited about this but
this is a way harder challenge than it
may seem because remember Luffy and the
crew were nearly thrown off their own
ship when they went through reverse
Mountain so how will he be doing that
hanging off the side of of the ship of
course at this point he doesn't have his
devil fruit so he doesn't have to worry
about losing his strength in the water
but in the end after fighting off some
very hungry fish Luffy overcomes the
challenge and together the world's
strongest swordsman and child Luffy head
off towards mihawk dark spooky and kind
of emo castle and now of course Luffy is
insanely excited I mean what upand
cominging swordsman wouldn't want to be
trained by the legendary mihawk however
there's some serious Danger here as well
that we simply can't Overlook because
remember that when Zoro landed on
mihawk's island the world's strongest
swordsman made him fight these quite
Savage Sword wielding mandrels as the
first part of his training and I mean if
Zoro had some trouble with these Apes
during the time skip then child Luffy is
surely going to be in very serious
trouble here so let's imagine that
mihawk gives Luffy some sort of training
first before then making him fight the
island beasts as well and on top of that
the Luffy is also going to have to learn
how to take care of himself as well
because mihawk won't always be at the
castle as we well know for example he'd
also need to learn how to cook and take
care of himself so basically he'd be
leveling up in all sorts of ways and so
let's say that after a few years on the
island Luffy has now improved his
swordsmanship to a just absurd degree
and has even started to learn the basics
of armament and observation hockey which
at this young age is just a stupidly
massive advantage that we'll talk about
more in just a moment but first though
mihawk finally decides to take him out
to fight an actual pirate but something
is going to happen next that is going to
absolutely ruin Luffy's training because
next they run into this random group of
pirates and as mihawk takes down the
captain he tells Luffy to wipe out the
rest of the crew and Luffy of course
does quite easily let's be honest after
all that insane training but there is
one one major problem here because when
mihawk comes back he finds that Luffy
has taken out all the underlings but he
has refus to cut even a single one of
them in other words yeah it does seem
like swordsman Luffy just like regular
Luffy just can bring himself to actually
kill someone so he basically beat them
down with the dull side of the sword
which I would imagine would probably be
quite problematic for mihawk who has no
trouble cutting down opponents As We
Know so he demands that Luffy actually
finish the job but Luffy being the good
person that we know him to be just can't
so mihawk finishes the job himself and
they return to the castle at a major
crossroads in the story here mihawk
gives lufia Choice decide to use his
sword to its fullest and continue his
training or leave the island for good
and this is honestly going to be kind of
heartbreaking since mihawk has trained
Luffy more than anyone ever did but
Luffy just can't bring himself to do it
for now I mean he's beating opponents
yeah but he doesn't want to kill them
when they're already down so he makes
the sad choice to actually leave I will
say props to him though for sticking to
his gut here and so from here and out
there are actually a few really
interesting options that would make
sense for what might happen next one I
don't think that mihawk would just
completely abandon and throw out Luffy
so maybe he'd give him to someone else
that he knows that has a good reputation
for example someone like Whitebeard who
is well known for taking orphans into
his crew he could also try to take him
back to Shanks but honestly I think the
most reasonable option would be for
Luffy to actually return to his hometown
in other words we're going back to the
east blue and the Goa Kingdom and if
you're a little bit disappointed here
wait a second because this is actually
the best time for Luffy to come back
because while he doesn't exactly have a
home here at this point Luffy should be
perfectly capable of taking care of
himself in the forest and even
befriending the these two Ruffians as
well and while this is admittedly a
little bit later in the timeline for the
boys to meet I'm still sure that they
would still get along just like normal
and very quickly become great friends in
fact the only reason Ace and Sabo were
originally hesitant to take in Luffy was
because he was young and weak but this
time there is no doubt that Luffy is way
stronger than these two older boys so
yeah remember that scorecard where Luffy
had zero wins I'm pretty sure that's
going to be very very different this
time around and so now let's uh skip
forward a little bit Sabo still decides
to leave and gets blown up apparently
and here is where we get our next major
change to Luffy's story because when Ace
finally decides to leave as well there
is no way in the world that swordsman
Luffy is staying behind even though he
is only 14 years old at this point
because even though he's still wants to
become pirate king he is also determined
to become the world's strongest
swordsman overcoming me Hawk and he
certainly can't do that just sitting
around on an island and so since he is
already so powerful swordsman Luffy is
coming along for the ride as well and I
think he's strong enough that Ace will
let him and if you actually read the ace
novels about Ace's story you will know
what will happen next the short of it
all is that they get Shipwrecked Ace
eats his powerful devil fruit and then
they journey through sabba ODI Fishman
Island and eventually reach wano and
then in the novels after leaving wano a
then travels around looking to take down
some yonko but let's back up here for a
second because while we are in the land
of the Samurai swordsman Luffy is going
to hop off the train at this point Luffy
is about 15 years old and he is just
absolutely in love with the idea of
training with some actual Samurai so
even though it's hard for him to leave
behind Ace and the Spade Pirates
swordsman Luffy can't resist the chance
to improve his skills here the only
problem is is that wano is currently
ruled by kaido and uh most of the real
Samurai have either been killed or
locked up so let's say that Luffy
travels around for a bit maybe he even
picks up a ranked sword or two since
this is wano and I'm sure they do have a
few of those lying around here and there
and I can even see him making some real
friends in the Lawless lands and the
left over town here outside of the
capital but at this point things will go
very very bad for him because because
let's be real for a second I just cannot
imagine Al Luffy sitting back and
letting his friends in the left over
town starve to death so maybe he does
something really rash like attacking a
food shipment or something and then he
steals food for the town and this is of
course going to get him into major
trouble in wano because we all know what
happened when Luffy did exactly that in
the original story so yeah that's not
going to end very well because as strong
as Luffy is with his sword skills his
hockey which could be pretty good after
a year of traveling with Ace and into
the new world he is still only 15 years
old at this point and way way weaker
than an actual yonko which means that
when he comes face to face with the
emperor he's going to get pretty badly
slapped by kaido however I still believe
that this brief fight would still be the
perfect time for Luffy to awaken his
actual conqueror hockey and even though
at this point it wouldn't really do
anything against kaido it might impress
press the king of the beasts enough to
throw Luffy in prison instead of you
know straight up killing him but you
won't believe what's going to happen
next because who else do we know in the
same prison as Luffy well there is of
course this old man known as Grandpa hoo
and who is this man well you know just
the most famous Yakuza boss in all of
wano country who also happens to know
the secrets of advanced armament hockey
and so after befriending this at this
point not quite as old man and learning
his Secrets Luffy goes through his own
little training Arc here now you might
be fairly enough saying that this might
be a little bit too early for Luffy to
learn about Advanced hockey and you
might be right but remember that he has
trained with basic hockey for at least 5
years at this point and traveled the
Seas for a year with Ace and so I would
argue that he has more than enough
experience to learn Advanced hockey at
this point as well I mean it is still
Luffy we're talking about here and so
after a couple of months of training
with his new skills Luffy frees himself
beats up the warden and of course as
Luffy does lead a prison break and this
makes Luffy a hero for the Escape
prisoners and they gladly offer to teach
Luffy their legendary swordsmanship in
the outskirts of wano which is of course
exactly what Luffy wants it however
Luffy's journey in wano is going to end
with a massive tragedy because kaido
won't just let a fullon prison break go
unpunished so I could see him sending
someone like the allstar Jack or someone
to recapture all the prisoners and while
Luffy would definitely put up a really
good fight at this point Jack's thick
Mammoth skin isn't damaged much by
Luffy's dll blade attacks remember he
still doesn't want to cut anyone at this
point which means that no one can
actually defeat Jack and in the end
grandpa hoo and the other prisoners
sacrificed themselves to allow Luffy to
escape which of course absolutely breaks
Luffy's heart similar to Marine Fort in
the original story so seriously this
would be the first major setback in his
life ever but now Luffy finally
understands what mihawk was trying to
teach him as a kid being a swordsman is
about knowing when to cut and when not
to cut and Luffy will never truly be a
true swords Master if he never chooses
to cut anything ever and so at this
point decides that he will continue his
journey and allow himself to cut down
anyone who tries to hurt his friends
tragically enough it is a really painful
lesson here but similar to AC's death
one that was important for Luffy to
learn and so what now I mean Luffy is
already at the end part of the grand
line but he isn't anywhere close to
reaching the top level of fighters in
the world yet and so honestly I think he
chooses to finally start his own pirate
journey and Conquer The Grand line like
he always was meant to do in other words
he's going to steal a ship and then
travels All the Way backwards to reverse
mountain now this of course would take
him a while especially on his own so now
he's 17 years old and basically starting
his journey at roughly the same time as
in the original story and at this point
there is one major question that we
simply must address because you might be
wondering what about all the other straw
hats because if Luffy is now skipping
these Al together then will he ever have
Zoro Nami Uso and Sanji join the crew in
the first place well the easy answer
with Zoro is no I mean I don't think
that Zoro would ever want to join
Luffy's crew if he sees him as a direct
rival for the world's strongest
swordsman title but don't worry we will
see more of Zoro in just a moment as for
the others though well it might surprise
you but he's actually going to go and
run into Nami very soon because remember
her goal early on in the story was to
steal a map of the grand line so let's
assume that she also made her way to the
Grand line as well to steal some more
treasure and let's conveniently assume
that she also runs into Luffy here and
after seeing how strong Luffy is she
does agree to tag along with him as well
but there is one condition and that is
that Luffy must go back to the east blue
with her and defeat arlong to free her
Village which honestly at this point
would pretty much be no problem at all
for a swordsman Luffy I mean sure he
doesn't have his devil fruit but he
already knows Advanced Armament and
basic observation hockey and has
awakened his conqueror hockey so without
a doubt Luffy would completely wipe the
floor with arlong's whole crew with
entire ease which means that Nami is
100% ready to follow Luffy anywhere now
the real question is what about the rest
of the crew and I think here might make
a lot of you really angry because I do
believe that at this point Luffy is much
less interested in traveling around the
East blue instead he is desperate to go
straight back to the Grand line and find
some really strong opponents to fight
instead which means that he's going to
miss out on Usopp and Sanji as well I do
think however that it would be very
fitting for him to run into Zoro though
at this point Zoro has become a famous
bounty hunter but he is simply no match
for Luffy at all which just means that
Zoro will swear to train way harder and
fight Luffy again in the future which
does mean that we're all packed up and
ready to go Luffy and Nami the two of
them head off to the Grand line where
their first goal is to find some truly
strong opponents to fight and of course
the closest big bat around is the
warlord crocodile who is in the process
of conquering Alabaster now Luffy may
not have the same connection to the
alabaster princess Viv as in the
original story but I'm sure that he
would still want to fight crocodile
nonetheless and hey I mean this time
around Luffy wouldn't even need to
figure out that sand is weak to water
since Luffy already knows how high
levels of hockey which means that this
fight ends very quickly with Luffy
slashing the warlord to Sandy bits in
their first encounter which now brings
us to our next major development for
swordsman Luffy in the story because
with crocodile defeated we now must ask
the question what happens to Nico Robin
well clearly she would want to tag along
with Luffy since Luffy has shown himself
to be quite powerful but would Luffy
even let her join the crew and honestly
I do think yeah I mean even though at
this point Luffy doesn't know Robin's
importance of finding the one piece he
would probably still trust his gut
instinct and let her join the crew he
still has the voice of all things and
still knows what people's true
intentions are so yeah it's just Luffy
and two women now sailing around the
Seas which I mean hey swordsman Luffy is
just a different type of guy and I guess
one piece has turned into a hor manga at
this point and actually now that we have
two crew mates it is time for for a
proper ship and since Luffy has already
traveled through the Grand line with Ace
he would probably already know about the
ship building Island water 7 and so the
three of them would head there to buy a
real ship now one thing to keep in mind
though is that on this island there are
government secret agents who are going
to kidnap Robin and it's very much
likely that in this chain of events that
would still very much occur but this
time around things are going to turn out
way way differently because originally
when Luffy fought these guys he got
absolutely crushed but now things are a
little bit different you know however
however before anyone can start swinging
a sword I do believe that the cp9 agents
would have an invitation for Luffy you
see since Luffy defeated Crocodile there
is an opening in the Warlords and the
world government would probably see
Luffy as a quite interesting candidate
to replace crocodile the only condition
is that Luffy has to give up Robin and
and then he can join which honestly
swordsman Luffy might consider the offer
for a second I mean just think about it
he could reunite with mihawk who is also
a warlord and fight tons of pirates
without ever having to worry about the
government but in the end he is still
Luffy and he still would reject the
offer and instead wipe out all of the
government agents all by himself with
absolute ease oh yeah I am saying that
Luffy at this point solos all of CP 9
and if you're somehow upset about that
get over it because swordsman Luffy is
just on a whole different level in our
story here and so with their new ship
ready to go you could say that Luffy
also picks up a ship right here but
honestly I kind of like the idea of
Luffy Nami and Robin just going about it
on their own as you know mihawk
certainly sails on his own so Luffy
might be inspired by his former Mentor
so let's skip ahead now to sabba Odi
where swordsman Luffy would meet the
right hand of the former pirate king Sil
rley and of course reallyy has heard
about Luffy from Shanks as well so well
I don't think we'd have this same
Auction House incident eventually
reallyy would just bust himself out and
run into Luffy which of course would
lead to their usual chat where reallyy
agrees to code Luffy's ship so that he
can go into the new world and so while
we avoid the entire Admiral and
separation incident this time around
there is one major obstacle before Luffy
can actually head back to the new world
which is of course news about Aces
planned execution which Luffy would
absolutely in this scenario also want to
stop and actually I don't think that
Luffy would be able to sneak into the
underwater prison which means that they
are headed off straight to Marine Fort
and oh boy this is going to be a major
major showcase for swordsman Luffy's
Powers because remember this will be his
first time seeing his old Mentor in many
many years on top of that he hasn't seen
Ace since before the fiery pirate joined
the Whitebeard Pirates as well in other
words a lot has happened over the last
few years for Luffy and of course I do
think that we can say that Luffy will
very much impress Whitebeard once again
it's very possible he would even clash
with mihawk for a second and while he
certainly isn't on his mentor level
quite yet Luffy is going to put up a
real fight with his Advanced hockey
conqueror hockey and extremely polished
sword skills in the end though there is
still one fatal flaw to swordsman Luffy
and that's because Luffy is now more of
an individual and while he has Nami and
Robin on his crew he is missing all of
the Escape prisoners from imple down who
originally helped him in this fight and
without all of that support to take out
some of the Marines I just don't think
that Luffy is strong enough on his own
at this point to fight through all the
Admirals and reach his brother so really
sorry Ace fans he once again is going to
die here which uh is a pattern
throughout most of these what if
scenarios but that's of course not the
end of swordman Luffy's story though
because even though he's of course
devastated by his longtime friend's
death I can still imagine Robin helping
Luffy escape and together they get away
just in time which is going to send
Luffy into a truly destructive rage but
this time Nami and Robin are there for
him and of course Luffy will come out of
this knowing that he needs to grow
stronger so it still makes a lot of
sense to have a 2-year time skip spend
training with rley who knows maybe lufia
even upgrades his weapon and since Luffy
is further along with his hockey skills
they can now spend their time perfecting
his Advanced hockey and improving his
sword techniques as well remember rley
is also a swordsman and so after 2 years
watch out because this swordsman Luffy
is going to be on a mission there is
absolutely no one who's going to be able
to even come close to stopping him in
the early arcs Post Time skip he's going
to sweep straight through this evil
fishermen this corrupt scientist and
yeah even through this stringy warlord
and although I do think that he would be
challenged by his longtime rival Zoro
along the way who surprisingly has made
up his own crew including Uso Sanji
Chopper and Frankie however after
learning about the road poneglyphs on zo
Luffy can then Focus Solly on collecting
the poneglyphs and finding the one piece
because he doesn't need to rescue Sanji
from Big Mom that's going to be now
zoro's problem which is going to take
him straight to wano to confront one of
the only people to ever actually defeat
him the emperor kaido and honestly I'm
sure that Luffy at this point would want
to go straight up and challenge the king
of the beasts one-on-one and honestly
that might not be the worst idea because
remember Luffy is now a truly
overpowered swordsman God and we do know
that kaido has some PTSD about legendary
Swordsman so there is a very good chance
that he could take down kaido on the
other hand though Luffy's overconfidence
here could also see him get smacked down
by the strongest creature in the world
because remember that Luffy could only
truly damage kaido once he unlocked his
major next power up and so let's imagine
that Luffy has gotten himself into a
truly desperate situation yeah he is
doing real damage to kaido but he can
finish him off but then kaido takes it
to the next level and is about to crush
Luffy with his massive club and with no
other strong crew mates to save him
Luffy is in real trouble until a certain
green-haired swordsman swoops in and
blocks kaido's attack you see Zoro can't
stand seeing his rival taken down by
someone else other than him so he does
battle with kaido as well which gives
Luffy some time to recover and of course
during this time he has also figured out
the secrets of advanced conqueror hockey
and then once again together Luffy and
Zoro fulfill wano's dream of finally
freeing the country from the legendary
dragon tyrants which also means that
Luffy has earned his second Road
poneglyph and is truly on the path now
to becoming pirate king and the world's
strongest swordsman however there are of
course still many tough challenges ahead
including confronting his two old
mentors mihawk and Shanks and you can
just bet that these two will have some
of the strongest hockey in the entire
Series so Luffy is going to to need a
major major power up in that department
before he can even dream of taking any
of them down in fact we've now seen how
strong Luffy has become with swords and
hockey but I've also always wondered how
strong Luffy would be if he only ever
used and trained with hockey no devil
fruits no weapons so if you want to see
if hoaky only Luffy is truly the
strongest version then you can watch
that video right here Shanks for
watching and I will be seeing you in the
next one